hands up guys my name is a general
welcome to the second Sparky dev vlog at
the dev vlog where we take a look at the
game engine that I'm making Sparky and
we are we see what what I did in the
past waking want my future plans our and
all that fun stuff every single Monday
so last time we did some day Bachmann
yourself and with yeah essentially I
kind of brought you guys up to up to
speed as to what I did in the past week
which is basically creating this debug
menu which just allowed us to control
values and this week I've kind of
started doing lighting stuff I don't
think any of this is committed really
right now but you can see that like for
now a scene basically has like a light
setup which is essentially just a bunch
of lights right and and and from then I
think I'm figuring some kind of way out
to maybe submit lighting setups to or
light setups to like render a 3d right
so we've got like light setup submission
and probably beginning to write some
actual I'm not sure if I did anything
yeah beginning to light being to write
some kind of lighting stuff in the
shaders and just getting a lighting to
work really and this is gonna be pretty
basic lighting to begin with I just want
to be able to this is of course has
nothing to do with the actual like
lighting model that you're using this is
simply a way for the renderer to
basically receive information about what
kind of lights you have set up in your
scene right so the problem that we've
got the problem that we're solving is
basically hey we're making a game for
example and we've got like we're in test
3d and we're making our game and
basically you know we want to be able to
set up our scene as needed with maybe
like a directional light for the Sun and
maybe a few point lights and we've got
like this whole set up so how do we get
that from the game to the shaders where
it actually has to be rendered that's
our problem right we have to think we
have to create some kind of pipeline
that takes us from point A to point B so
from game side to the actual shaders all
the way down the
down the road when we actually start
rendering things so that's what this is
all about and I'm kind of still figuring
out the best way to do that but I just
really haven't had too much time to work
on it this week unfortunately been a
really busy week for me I've been
migrating the channel comms service and
to a completely different server and
there's been all all this other stuff
that's happened this week very exciting
week so um I didn't have as much time on
the forth later work on Sparky as I as I
wish I did and this is this should be
set up to be mad mode anyway that's kind
of the idea of what I have been working
on and what I'm gonna be working on this
week now one of the things I wanted to
talk to you guys about because you know
I didn't add too many things are all
really this week so there's not much to
talk about what I did want to do is
actually go through a lot of what the
future holds for Sparky so I've opened
up the Trello board which you can all
access by going to Sparky so by going to
bitly four slash Sparky Trello a little
bit link in description we're gonna kind
of go through this and we're going to
triage it so we're going to basically
assign a priority towards all these
things that need to be done and we're
probably gonna add some other features
as well and you this is a public board
you can all comment on stuff and
there'll be a lot of interactive things
that you guys can kind of do to get
involved but basically yes so it
continues integration so the way that
everything's made by the way if I show
the menu and we can see the labels the
color coding is pretty simple there's
there's low priority things which are
green there's medium which is yellow
high which is orange critical so
critical things are basically blockers
right so these are like things that have
to be done ASAP because they block other
tasks from being done right future is
stuff that we'll probably explore in the
far future right
and then current is more or less in
progress stuff right so stuff that I'm
currently working on right now so for
example lighting and that lighting setup
thing would be an example of something
that's current so it's the color coding
that we're going with right so we know
that for example this stuff has high
priority control support as well
like high priority and then like it is
integration is like medium so can do
continuous integration is something I
would want to set up and basically all
that means is I've got like a build
machine that every time I commit a new
code to Sparky it essentially just does
a build like it does a debug builds and
areolis build and then commits those
binaries to the repository and that's
just a good way to see that I haven't
broken code it's not as as vital or I
haven't broken the build rather but it's
not it's not as vital to do right now
because we only support one platform and
basically if it compiles in Windows then
it's going to compile like if it can
pass for me locally it's pretty much
almost guaranteed to compile for
everyone right the only place that it
would be useful right now is say I
forget to commit a file or something
like I've added a file and I forgot to
actually like add it to get then of
course the bill would fail and I'd be
like oh I brought in the build and I'd
be like gods because I forgot this file
right so it's a good thing to to keep
around just to make sure that that the
repository is actually accurate and that
anyone anyone should be able to build
the code theoretically without any
errors but especially when we get like
Mac and Linux going and then maybe even
other platforms like mobile that will be
way more important because if I like
commit something knowing me like I
wouldn't test it on all platforms I just
kind of commit code and see what happens
so if I kind of do some changes that a
platform independent and and they happen
to to compile fine under say MSV C but
then under clang or GCC or something G
plus plus they don't compile for some
reason or it generates successive
warnings or something I'm not sure but
let's just say that it doesn't compile
then I would know right because yeah so
when we have like well when we started
dragging in other compilers for other
platforms that will become much more
useful better debugging support I wish I
added a comment here that or a
description that said what this was but
I assume this was kind of the debug menu
stuff because this was a while ago
so I assumed that this was kind of the
debug menu stuff and just generally
being able to debug better so that's
always gonna be hi
generally controller support so that's
adding you know basically the ability to
hook up controllers to your computer and
and basically get an advanced system
going for that where we can respond to
controller events so that's something
that I've marked as high just because
it's not it's not gonna be too difficult
to actually put in and I think that um I
think that is kind of important in the
sense that you know it's great to just
like if you were just want to make a
quick game that you can even just well
first of all write it every entrance
should have this anyway
but I mean that to make a quick demo
game I think a good way to show off the
demo is by using using a controller just
because you can kind of stand back and
let people look at the screen and you
don't have to be kind of with a keyboard
and mouse in an inconvenient location so
it's a good thing I I want to do it
quickly because it also gives you kind
of the ability to make a quick game that
you can just create maybe in a couple
hours
awful lot um there or something and then
you can just chuck it onto like the TV
and you can play it out with your
friends or something and really I just I
I just want to get control support done
like as quickly as possible
alright so show you the compilation
issues on AMD cards this is a bug so
this is under the bugs and issues
category this is a bug that I am not
even sure if so investigate the
relevance of this because I'm really not
sure whether or not this is actually
still a thing because I remember this
was like a this was like an issue on
github that I didn't fix that was open
maybe eight or ten months ago so because
I've rewritten a lot of stuff maybe I
have solved this but I'm not sure so we
are going to just probably add like a
low label to it just because I don't
really care about it too much right now
if people do complain about this more
than I will bump it up
but for now I'm not gonna really worry
about that also I don't have access to
any AMD cards so
yeah like I'm not even gonna like I've
got a few old laptops I think that have
like 80 i cants but I don't I don't use
them really because like hey let's be
real who use the same day anyway the
point is that from start of war
I don't really do that okay WebGL
texture issues this is also something
that needs investigation fix web build
first riot so but it was pretty this is
much more urgent than this kind of move
this up maybe I should kind of keep
these this stuff sorted as well let's do
that actually so this is kind of what I
want to do somewhat alright so we've got
tools so there's a tool so one of the
biggest tools actually that I've
forgotten is the CLI generator so
so this is just to generate this stuff
and I'm actually going to put that on
medium because I want that done you sent
me quickly so of course what I mean by
that is being able to wrap all this tape
a small code in CLI stuff kind of like
what we had with the spiking CLI
although that was manual whereas I want
to write a tool that does that for you
and I've kind of I need to add the tool
to this repository actually but
basically all it would do is stuff like
this right where then you can see how
whole this is like this uses like this
[ __ ] namespace in some of that but
all this would do is you know basically
just call the C below do any kind of
conversions that you need to do such as
marshaling and stuff for that to work
but basically just wrap all the C++
calls in these CLI calls that can be
accessed by say sharp
so that's I want to do that because I
want to be able to play around in
c-sharp with Sparky and of course by
creating the CLI generator I'm basically
making me I'm basically just adding C
sharp as a language that you can use to
make games since barking right for
Windows
alright so build tool and Visual Studio
an integration that I did not spell
correctly so let's just fix that up yeah
so a build tool is just going to be like
a tool that you can use to basically
format stuff for Sparky right it's not
that necessary just yet because we don't
have any custom formats like once we
have this custom model format obviously
we need a way to go from you know our
raw assets into the actual engine run
time format assets right so that's what
the built will kind of be used for so
this is very this is like a lower
basically and then Visual Studio
integration and also by build tool and
visual studio integration I'm also
talking about having some kind of visual
studio plug-in that I can use to just
build Sparky for like you know the web
for example right so that I don't have
to run like some kind of batch file and
constantly updated with the files that I
want to compile I can just you know run
that tool run that plug-in and it will
just it'll just complete right
it'll just automatically set up the web
build and and and compile it with
inscription right so that's kind of like
I really catch you much about that right
now so we're gonna mike has a low and
then the level editor I do kind of want
to make this level editor so this is
going to be and I've been talking with
with this guy here about he's been
asking some questions about stuff and
there's some discussion going on here
which you can also check out but
basically the idea for the level editor
is just gonna be a scene editor for now
we're not gonna worry about stuff like
scripting because we're you know we
don't really have a scripting language
and um inspire yet and I still haven't
decided which one I want to use so still
waiting on that but when we do pick one
we'll probably integrate that with level
editor but for now I just want to I just
want it to be a way like well we can
essentially just um place objects and
you know set up like the environment you
know set up lights all that stuff for a
scene so that we don't have to do that
in code we can just kind of do that in
the editor and that all of course
sterilized into some kind of level
format which we can load at runtime so
civilization is kind of the blocker for
this really because we can't do anything
will level it or until the striations of
its own I mean obviously I could start
writing like the GUI and stuff for this
but this is a big task however I do want
it no I'm gonna markers medium because I
do want it to actually happen soon so
we're gonna pop it up here probably
before this stuff which also kind of
brings me to serialization which does
need to be done so this is actually
going to be high because it's important
so I'll put it like maybe here because
yeah I mean civilization just making
some kind of sparking sterilization
format so that we can serialize out data
and then deserialize it at runtime so
that we can essentially load custom
files like custom file formats such as
the level file format that we create and
all that stuff that's
so we need to do that otherwise we can't
hit level editor okay cool so 3d stuff
forward rendering deferred rendering and
custom model amount I'm also going to
our add a physically based rendering
which the PBR because that's going to be
the primary workflow of Sparky
so for rendering I do want to pretty
much finish that first so this is going
to be basically current right because we
are currently working on it
deferred rendering is going to be high I
want to do that very soon custom model
from format is gonna be probably fairly
high but I'll put it as medium and then
physically based rendering is also going
to be high so that's kind of the order
that we're doing it in as well so let's
talk about this a little bit so for
rendering is what we've got right now
and deferred rendering is what I want to
implement very soon possibly well I want
to I want to have it fully working by
the end of February so by the end of
next month it should be completely
working and perfect as well as probably
physically based rendering so these two
tasks really I want to have done by by
February now whether or not I could like
you know physically better rendering has
nothing to do with deferred rendering I
could potentially do that first and set
it up for forward rendering in fact I
probably will do that so we'll do
physically based rendering first perhaps
maybe we'll probably do this at the same
time I think but for rendering is what
we need to finish right now which is all
the kind of stuff that we had about our
current way which is just you know
submitting much of objects rendering the
scene not too much much deferred
rendering is rendering all of our scene
initially two different buffers so that
we can then reconstruct the lighting
once we know you know stuff like a
occlusion and what actually does get
rendered so that we don't waste time
calculating stuff for every single light
in our frame anyway that's not the
moment talk about how that works now but
basically it's important for having like
tons of dynamic lights right if you have
any more I'm pretty sure like if you
have more than 2.2 dynamic lights in
your scene then deferred rendering is
going to be fast in the forward
rendering so the only downside with
deferred rendering is support because
you
to have multiple render targets
available to you which not all platforms
support for example glares - does not
support that because three I believe
does I'm gonna have to double check that
but I think so all current desktop of
course support that but I'm just saying
like some mobile devices don't so there
are a few limitations with it but that's
pretty much it it's just pretty much
better in every way
almost and yet custom or more format we
need a way to go from something like
going from like FBX pretty much which is
probably what we're going to go from to
spark your runtime format so FBX is a
model format Autodesk model format which
is pretty commonly used in the industry
and it's not it's not exactly like it's
not exactly optimized for runtime or
anything but has all the all the
information we need so what we want to
do is go from that format into a format
that we are designed specifically for
like loading speed essentially an
efficiency so we want to be able to have
a Sparky model format that we can just
chuck into the engine and it's like
format it's already formatted in such a
way that we can just kind of pop it into
memory and that's it we don't need to
parse it or read like add stuff to it we
can just take all we need we can just
basically take all that memory and put
it into like an Open GL buffer and then
just render it right if we want to it
has to be it we want to make it as close
to the actual runtime memory layout
pretty much as we can as we can right
because that means that we'd have to
waste time like loading it and like
converting it on the fly right we can do
that offline we can do that like before
the game starts so that's something that
we need to do of course because I don't
want to like currently the engine
supports obj as it's like only format
and you'll see stuff like that in the
model class that's all the model class
has right now if you look at this so
load will basically just go through the
obj like it's a text file and pass it
and then insert vertices and indices and
all that stuff in
here and eventually of course create the
buffer and right now I think it doesn't
even support like a bunch of stuff but
um roughly like it'll work that's how we
actually get the cube in the sphere here
they're both obj files so yeah so we
definitely need to do that okay 2d stuff
API considerations so what do I mean by
AVR considerations well I just mean
cleaning up the API adding all the
missing features and making it nice so I
just want to be able to basically clean
up the API that we have so what I mean
by that is if we go to render a 2d I
have kind of been adding stuff as I go
along so if we look at what we support
like for example you know we've got draw
line we've got draw rect we've got draw
string but like we're missing stuff like
well you know what if we want to draw a
circle like what we want to fill a
circle or an ellipse or something or
triangle you know like we're missing a
lot of these kind of primitive drawing
things as well as maybe like for example
we might want to make more overloads for
these which take different parameters I
don't a pretty good job by just using a
lot of default parameters as you can see
so it's not that vital this kind of
makes so how our overloads a lot a lot
less of them like defined explicitly but
yeah and just making sure that like the
batch render supports all these
different things that we want to do and
making sure that the API is kind of
complete right as well as making sure
that yeah if we want to just render
something it shouldn't be necessarily
too difficult to do okay so that's gonna
be kind of local I actually think it's
kind of alright for now I want to put it
as lawyer I'm gonna it's kind of alright
optimizations as well I don't really see
the need to optimize it too much when I
that is low there are a few things there
are very few things there right there
are a few things we could do to optimize
it
most of this stuff is pretty good like
the submission I think is fairly optimal
as it for drawing lines if we look at
yes'm it like this stuff is kind of yeah
like this stuff is very well optimized
in terms of like it lines up with the
CPU cache very well and like we do
recalculate this stuff but we only do
that because it's faster than actually
caching them and retrieving them so
generally I think this is fairly well
optimized I'm not gonna go through it
slowly now but also I just I think it's
fast enough as well like it's pretty
good there are potentially some things I
think we haven't looked at draw a string
with my optimization eyes yet so maybe
that could be potentially better and all
of this stuff as well was kind of
implemented in a hurry but um yeah but
generally I think is good like it's it's
good it's I haven't had any problems
with speed at all like I've just put up
to my - is there because I think at one
point or two I would have noticed some
things where I was like oh I could
probably make that faster which is why
it's also low priority so properly a
material integration what I mean by that
is if we go to like our layer 2 days and
this is of course in in like in the 2d
development list so it's to do with that
you know like layers right now when we
create a layer so if we look at test to
test layer and this is of course a 2d
layer when we create it we kind of
specify a shader for it and like an
orthographic matrix for it and that's
kind of it like we don't um like we've
kind of specified which shader we want
to use for it and then which matrix but
what I think instead we should do is
kind of like what we did with test 3d
where we just had like materials of
course cuz materials are essentially
shaders with a bunch of parameters right
now like textures potentially that's
like one of the parameters one of the
possible parameters we and then we of
course create materialism and stuff like
that and the idea is maybe you know it
there
should actually just take him like a
material instance essentially right
because we don't of course when we're
rendering stuff as 2d layers and we
rendering 2d objects they don't need
separate shaders right because there's
no such thing as that you can of course
that certain parameters the shaders per
object that you want to render but
sprites generally are rendered with the
same shader that's just how games
typically work if they're 2d surprised
so because of that I think layers should
have materials rather than sprites of
course so that's just you know that
stuff is I'm going to mark it as medium
just because it's not that big but job
but it will probably make everything a
lot better box 2d where market is medium
but it's more of a lower because I don't
really care too much about that right
now I'm doing graphic stuff for 3d and I
imagine I'll probably start doing like
physics and 3d physics for 3d stuff so
but this is more or less waiting on like
the component system so finish entity
component system let's not make that
happen so this this is also going to be
kind of medium I think and then the the
UI framework stuff is probably going to
be it so many checkboxes text fields
like I don't really care too much about
that to be honest because we're not
really working on that stuff right now
let's move this down yeah but that's
kind of the idea all right platform
stuff platform dependent stuff so we've
got Mac and Linux yeah
medium like I do want to get that stuff
done but I also kind of want to make
sure that we do the main engine first
because I have no need to support this
right now like obviously when you're
releasing a game or something you would
want to support that but
the development of the engine itself I
pretty much never used I okay first of
all I never used Mac and Linux for
development I use Mac's kind of
frequently sent me frequently but not
for development no so I don't really
care too much about that in scope of
development but I know that you guys do
so that's why if Marta's medium and not
lot literally just because you guys web
I would say is in the same boat as that
and then mobile is kind of be low
priority because I don't care too much
about that right now it's something that
I would like the engine to eventually
support but it's also not something that
I'm going to just stop everything and
start doing because that's not an easy
task either and that's going to involve
platform-specific code like extensive
level specific code for that like I'm
talking like Java and objective-c for
the platform layer so I don't really
want to do too much about that
so yeah anyway that's I think that's
about it so really 3d development is
kind of what I'm working on right now
with for rendering so lights and live
setups
is in general exactly what I'm doing in
fact I could probably just delete this I
think it might be a better idea to to
delete this how do I delete this do I
have to archive at kindest archive
whatever so maybe I should add like a
checklist for forward rendering to do
so we could do stuff like lights and
light setups
what else do what else do we need to do
I think I want to fix up the uniform
stuff we've got like batching and
sorting and textures manners a lot so
textures batching sorting probably like
visibility checking and by that I mean
stuff like culling
yeah which involves stuff like occlusion
queries and like all that stuff and we
probably want what was that other thing
that was on my mind
uniform work
so like Fischetti uniforms what was that
big thing I was thinking of just then it
was like I was important I'd probably do
that damn what was I thinking of Ford
rendering what else do I need
oh this is great
I like this to do this though so we'll
do like well we'll do a few things that
are already marked off so it's geometry
sub mesh submission just done so kind of
make that off the render commands are
pretty much done
to comment so you were already 25% of
the way done hey I don't remember what I
was going to say but it was pretty
important and I've forgotten it so
Lowell yeah so those thing about
batching sorting visibility checking oh
yeah that's right render flags that's
what I was going to say so render flags
probably gonna go around here and then
what kind of uniform work render flag no
I do it in in this order I think so yes
so by render flags I mean like the
renderer has it like you should be able
to sense to set certain flags for the
renderer that you do in between drill
core such as like an example would be
stuff like blend states but also like
lighting setups is also like a flag
right or um maybe like certain like
system uniforms and stuff like that as
well is a good example of render flags
and like for example like our shadows on
or off like stuff like that right so
this is kind of the dealio so got a lot
of stuff to do there this stuff as well
like goodness me there'll be a lot of
subjective visit for for physically
based rendering and deferred rendering
so that's a lot but this column is kind
of what I'm actually working on right
now I can see it's marked with purple as
well anyway guys that's going to wrap it
up for this dev vlog 30 minutes a might
how do people make dev vlogs that are
like under 20 minutes long I don't get
it this was a dev vlog keep in mind
where I had absolutely nothing basically
to show that I did in the past week
apart from like about lighting setup
kind of just skeleton class right I been
through did nothing and somehow I still
found 30 minutes of stuff to talk about
regarding what I would do yeah anyway do
you guys enjoy this video then please
please hit like button and of course if
he didn't hit if he didn't enjoy the
video hit the dislike button and tell me
why he didn't like it maybe I can
prove the enjoyment your enjoyment of
the next of the future deadlocks you
also join these sparking slack or just
the might slack in general which is
called slacked off the train home where
you'll be able to talk about Sparky all
day long with people who are as
interested in the project as you are and
you can just join the slack basically by
going to select off the train home and
of course if you are if you are a
superfan and you really want to help out
the development of Sparky and you want
to see more videos then you want to head
over to my patreon where you can pledge
a certain amount per month and you pool
you will receive some cool rewards and I
have yet to come up with some Sparky
rewards but but don't you worry now that
I've got like a logo for Sparky and
stuff maybe I'll start making like mugs
and t-shirts and cool stuff like that to
give away to the patrons and and stuff
like that anyway thanks for watching
guys I'll see you next week with the dev
vlog number three during the week I'll
probably put out that how Sparky works
video the dogs talking about so they'll
be like midweek maybe like Wednesday
Thursday Friday sometime around them and
yeah I'll see you guys next week goodbye